c'est pas du tout ni faire un tu ni rien
on a fait un disque voilà c'était déjà
pas mal
la liquide bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout mon appareil merci vous êtes né le
10 octobre 1947 à Strasbourg alors
cookie en fait c'est un surnom qui vous
est donné par votre maman depuis le plus
jeune âge parce que pense à grossesse
elle avait une amie canadienne qui
appelait son fils comme ça et voilà vous
avez essayé de changer mais c'est
impossible jamais être vraiment c'est
Christian bon vraiment c'est Christian
alors votre père bel homme élégant
qu'elle est bien réussi en montant un
cabinet de géomètre il avait attendu
votre mère 17 ans
car votre grand-mère maternelle voulait
un gendre avec une meilleure situation
et votre mère était cloîtrée dans sa
chambre au troisième étage où son jules
votre père la rejoignait en catimini en
faisant des terribles acrobaties mais
quand la fortune de la grand-mère a été
dilapidée par le frère de la grand-mère
qui était un flambeur et un buveur là
votre père voilà il a installé dans un
appartement il a enfin pu cueillir le
fruit défendu oui belle histoire d'amour
ah c'est magnifique vous êtes le fruit
d'un amour clandestin mûri pendant 17
ans ça se voit
en plus d'être fils unique surproé gâter
parce que j'avais un frère
donc vous êtes vraiment
le petit dieu quoi oui
c'est handicap c'est lourd à porter
souvent alors jeunesse doré évidemment
mais cancre à l'école
oui oui pas intéressé par l'histoire pas
du tout pas du tout j'ai fait je passais
dans les classes supérieures grâce à mes
bu au football et puis sans doute aussi
à des chèques de mon père dans les
réunions et pour les caresses du collège
des différents collèges mais non c'était
pas mon truc finalement on vous met un
terme chez les Jésuites à Dole et là
vous trouvez rapidement un moyen
d'échapper une heure par jour à
l'internat vous prenez des cours
particuliers de piano oui parce que je
vais remarquer que les gars qui
prenaient le piano pouvaient quitter
l'étude pour aller faire leurs petits
exercices dans des petites chambres où
il y avait un petit piano sans espoir de
vous inculquer le solfège finalement le
prof de piano conseil votre père
d'installer un piano dans votre chambre
pour que vous fassiez vos chancelets
incroyable mon père a subi ce conseil
dans la lettre il disait notamment il
disait ce serait pour son équilibre je
trouve que ce serait du plus grand bien
qu'il puisse avoir un piano parce que
moi je jouais les Beatles ça doit enfin
les morceaux de l'époque et voyez bien
que j'y prenais plein de plaisir même si
je ne bossais pas les exercices
prescrits et puis donc on a mis un piano
dans ma chambre et j'ai appris en
autodidacte voilà alors vous dites je ne
sais toujours pas lire les notes mais
j'ai une oreille diabolique ouais ouais
bah diabolique comme beaucoup d'autres
musiciens qui ont pris la musique comme
ça quand j'entends un truc à la radio je
peux je peux l'évoquer tout de suite
dans la foulée alors après les études
vraiment poussives en architecture vous
êtes pas très désireux de reprendre le
cabinet géomètre de votre père et là
vous montez vos premiers groupes de rock
dont tant que ça fait Joker
beaucoup de beaucoup de musique
anglo-saxonne évidemment grand fan du
Velvet grand fan
des Stones évidemment voilà plus des
morceaux à nous des morceaux à nous
écrit en anglais avec maintenant avec le
recul je vois avec des textes quand même
relativement indigent comme seul un
petit français alsacien peut en écrire
voilà mais mets une musique quand même
bien charpentée des très bons
guitaristes et quand je réécoute les
banques je me dis que c'était quand même
un sacré groupe à l'époque un peu en
avance peut-être pour la région dans son
temps alors ensuite vous participez à
l'aventure du lancement d'un resto
macrobiotique vous passez quelques mois
en Afghanistan et vous finissez par vous
installer dans le sud de la France là
vous donner des cours de tennis vous
jouez dans les clubs vous faites la
tournée des plages à Nice à Cannes des
clubs des clubs de cocktails clubs
un petit peu alors vous installez dans
un mât en compagnie de Béatrice la mère
de votre enfant Tom mais elle a peur des
frelons
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ça a été le
motif avancé pour quitter ce pays de
rêve et l'endroit de rêve on avait 5
hectares avec les oliviers et tout
c'était pour c'était vraiment
extraordinaire mais bon jeune maman le
bébé beaucoup de frelons voilà une envie
peut-être aussi de finalement c'était
pas si mal qu'on se retourne à
Strasbourg j'ai pu reprendre contact
avec ma famille j'étais un peu en froid
ils étaient quand même grands-parents il
y avait il y avait tout ça parce que
c'était pas possible parce que vous
draguiez les filles à qui vous donniez
des cours de tennis c'est pas possible
je pense que
vous croyez je pense que peut-être alors
là vous réalisez que vous serez jamais
un tennisman professionnel ni un
footballeur professionnel vous avez fait
du ballon aussi et vous décidez à ce
moment-là de vous consacrer
exclusivement à la musique et en 1984
femme libérée qui va devenir un méga
tube alors l'histoire commence en fait
en 81 c'est une musique que vous aviez
composée et un jour une fixe qui
s'appelle Joël Coppe qui est votre
voisine du dessus à Strasbourg qui veut
être chanteuse vous propose d'écrire des
paroles c'est-à-dire pas une mauvaise
parolière parce qu'elle a fait après des
chansons pour Zazie et elle vous dit je
vais t'écrire un texte là-dessus c'était
la seule chanson française de toute
l'insecte anglo-saxon aussi bien de nos
morceaux que de reprise et déjà à cette
époque cette chanson les gens je me
souviens qu'on jouait au top 56 venez
nous dire ah c'est bien là ton truc là
la femme machin là voilà mais c'était
complètement hors production ordisk
chanson qu'on avait fait un peu par défi
parce que Joël vous chantiez toujours en
anglais donc la boutade ça avait été bah
écris nous une chanson et c'est ça toute
première chanson alors il faudrait quand
même trois ans pour cette chanson soit
enregistrée un jour vous êtes dans un
bal d'une grande école à Paris et le
producteur de l'émission de France 3
l'Echo des bananes vous dit pourquoi on
en fait pas un 45 tours ce sera l'un des
plus gros tubes du Top 50 un million et
demi de single vendus 18 semaines dans
le classement c'était énorme c'est fou
c'est fou ça a été rapide votre
célébrité quand même très rapide parce
que le disque sorti si j'ai bonne
mémoire en avril ou en mai et puis ça a
été le tube de l'été et puis c'est
d'autant plus incroyable que que cette
phrase résonnera toujours dans ma tête
quand on rentre de Paris vers Strasbourg
Paul le guitariste qui dit juste cette
phrase forme une œuvre vous rendez
compte si on avance 50000 personnes ne
perdent d'argent pour vous dire que vous
pensez pas du tout ni faire un tu ni
rien on a fait un disque voilà c'était
déjà pas mal alors quels ont été les
réactions de votre entourage à ce
moment-là votre père par exemple
à mon père toujours très secret
évidemment
je me suis bien sûr c'est un plaisir lui
offrir le premier disque d'or qu'il a
effectivement accroché à la plus belle
place de son salon mais il prenait ça
dans
un peu de haut il m'a jamais vraiment ni
encourager ni rien et ce n'est que
évidemment comme souvent après sa mort
que j'ai découvert des dossiers qu'il
avait il découpaient les articles mais
tout absolument tout des lettres de ces
confrères etc où j'ai vraiment réalisé
il était très fier mais il n'a jamais pu
me le dire c'est une famille on parle
peu et c'est un peu c'est un peu dommage
mais j'ai trouvé tout ça après
évidemment ça m'a extrêmement ému c'est
sûr votre mère j'imagine
non très fier évidemment et Béatrice
Béatrice c'est souvent la fille la plus
rebelle que ce qui m'était donné de
rencontrer donc rebelle à tout rebelle
aussi à ça un vrai Gémeaux si tenté
qu'on puisse croire aux astres mais
vraiment oui ensuite non je lèche et
après je mords une fille vraiment
difficile à vivre mais qui a tenu sa
route jusqu'à nous quitter il y a pas
longtemps dans un excès
d'alcool de tout vraiment un excès et
donc elle prenait ça un petit peu comme
elle comme une vraie sauvage peut le
prendre un peu amuser etc elle a jamais
elle n'a jamais été fière donc ce que je
faisais elle n'a jamais non plus été
contre elle se souvient et c'est ça que
j'ai toujours aimé chez elle elle se
souvient des années où on faisait de la
musique jusqu'à 4h du matin en jouant
les vieux morceaux des années 70-80 bien
avant d'être connu ayant connu cette
période là et bien sûr elle a été
attachée à ça elle était attachée à ça
bien sûr et Tom et Tom va bien Tom
évidemment je l'ai découvert pas
tardivement mais c'est vrai que j'étais
rarement là voilà à l'époque il avait
non non pas du tout et par la suite
évidemment c'était comme tous les tubes
des années 80 il y a un moment où ça
devient un peu ringard la variété
française imagine qui commençait à
écouter du rap comme beaucoup de gamme à
son âge donc il était un peu et c'est
finalement ses copains mais c'est génial
c'est un des premiers reggae français où
il a peut-être reconsidéré peut-être le
morceau mais en tout cas maintenant on
s'entend super bien c'est déjà arrivé de
travailler ensemble
quels ont été vos relations avec les
médias à l'époque
j'ai été vite gavé disons par Paris bah
oui on venait on faisait de la musique
live depuis des années on se retrouve à
faire des playbacks dans les boîtes de
nuit à 3h du matin
à droite à gauche Paris est-ce que c'est
ma nature profondément alsacienne
peut-être je sais pas mais mais bon puis
ça ça parlait beaucoup ça c'était un peu
particulier donc on s'est laissé un peu
un peu basculer vous aviez des papiers
vous aviez des émissions de télé mais
c'est pas c'est bien sûr voilà fasciner
les médias voilà je veux dire on peut
pas vraiment être fier d'avoir fait un
double page dans Mademoiselle âge tendre
voilà quel est votre repas préféré bon
voilà au bout d'un moment c'est bon mais
il y a eu des merveilles il y a eu un
double page de France dimanche que j'ai
gardé qui est merveilleux une vraie
fiction ils sont morts de faim ils n'ont
plus qu'une boîte de choucroute la
voisine arrive à une chanson enfin ça me
fait que je gagne de l'argent oui
sûrement quel était le meilleur moment
de cette époque
c'est quand même d'avoir comment
dirais-je fait soi-même une petite
mélodie un petit air
maintenant je sais qu'il est devenu
qu'il est rentré dans plein de foyer
mais je me souviens je me souviens d'une
petite anecdote qui m'avait vraiment
vraiment plaisir nous allions jouer à
Bordeaux donc trouvions pas la salle
c'était donc en 84 on était là avec la
camionnette le matin le poignard de son
etc et on veut juste demander à des gens
où se trouve le parce que c'était un
palais des glaces et on s'arrête pour
demander à trois jeunes filles et elles
avancent en marchant et elle chante
femme libérée ne sachant pas du tout que
c'était vous et nous bien sûr ne leur
disons rien et je trouve ça fait
réalisé ce morceau peut être un lien
comme ça invisible entre plein de gens
et ça ça m'avait ça m'avait beaucoup
touché et le pire moment de cette époque
c'est
c'est de ne plus faire de musique quoi
c'est de ne plus être créatif et puis de
ce de se cacher de se cacher des trucs
de s'enfermer ça m'est arrivé tard il
faut pas oublier familibrer j'ai 37 ans
c'est pas comme la star que j'ai 20 ans
etc donc voilà j'ai essayé de trouver
une marque j'ai eu vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de mal après vous faites un
deuxième single qui s'appelle faux pas
rêver ça s'est prémonitoire en même
temps et puis et puis surtout il fallait
surtout pas sortir ce morceau là alors
j'ai fait encore quelques voyages à
Paris pour dire aux producteurs que
c'était une erreur de vouloir faire une
deuxième femme libérée je pense qu'il
fallait planter un autre clou de faire
autre chose mais c'est pas nous qui
décidions du choix des morceaux et puis
je pense que moi j'ai pas fait non plus
peut-être les musées
c'est pas impossible justement là
finalement la promo vous faitesigue les
tournez vous fatigue vous détournez de
la musique et vous mettez le nez dans
les héros quoi comme moi j'ai pas d'avis
à donner sur la question
si ce n'est que c'est un piège énorme et
que c'est énorme je connais personne qui
a été plus fort que le produit voilà et
donc et donc voilà c'était aussi une
façon de voir un peu peut-être de
m'isoler de fermer la porte et de et de
retourner à Strasbourg à ce moment-là
alors vous dites une journée sans zéro
était invivable ma seule activité
consistait à trouver l'argent d'abord la
drogue ensuite j'étais en apnée je
m'isolais de tout et de tous bien sûr
c'est vrai qu'au début ça résume tout on
a plus faim on a plus envie de baiser on
a plus envie de réussir
pour être mieux puis après on en prend
juste pour être normal malade et puis
finalement on s'accroche aux médicaments
quoi
c'était c'était fou vraiment et puis on
se manque complètement là c'est comme
une plante qui a besoin de terre
et le corps a tellement besoin de ça que
même le même le cerveau se met de la
partie pour trouver une raison une
excuse d'aller encore et ça va pour
assurer si enfin il faut que j'assure
mes parents les excuses sont nombreuses
et le trou est sans fin vraiment là vous
vous trouvez en train de ramper devant
des minables juste parce qu'ils peuvent
vous vendre un migram Nero quoi c'est à
dire c'est très c'est très humiliant en
même temps sauvé c'est ce qui va sauver
l'âge c'est plus possible je là c'est
plus possible c'est pas moi je ne peux
pas et ça plus voilà plus
j'en ai marre je sais c'est devenu
physique j'en dors mais plus des
cauchemars et là il faut trouver il faut
trouver une sortie quoi et vous en êtes
sortis oui grâce à quelqu'un évidemment
pour vous résoudre à décrocher et
ensuite décrocher oui oui bien sûr aussi
parce que j'étais avec quelqu'un d'autre
et donc j'avais rencontré Cathy sur un
sur un spectacle voilà on était tombé
amoureux mais bon c'est pas question et
puis chose incroyable cette fille m'a
attendu patiemment 4-5 ans malgré ses
parents ou ces familles que tu attends
à faire je dis souvent anecdote terrible
quand elle était allée voir des gens
spécialisés en leur demandant vous qui
connaissez la drogue donnez moi un
conseil le seul conseil que client
donnait c'est planquer votre carte bleue
c'est fou et donc comme quoi j'ai perdu
d'avance mais derrière il y a un
problème qui dit 9h30
évidemment et donc quand même bon
finalement ne sachant plus que faire et
temps perdu je suis un peu allé vers
elle dans les années vraiment envie et
donc elle m'a le combat c'est soi-même
personne peut le faire à votre place
mais au moins elle a tout planifié
autour s'occuper de j'avais plus
d'excuses disons il y a une scène
incroyable c'est le jour où vous allez
en cuir de désintoxication la voiture
tombe en panne sur le chemin de
l'hôpital absolument et là vous êtes
dépanner par un pote et vous voyez dans
dans son regard qui doute que vous
puissiez décrocher quoi il me dit bonne
chance mais je vois bien qu'il y croit
pas ça vous a foutu la pêche toujours eu
besoin comme ça de challenge je vais te
montrer quand même que je suis pas si
dingue que ça
et là ça va oui oui je vais m'arrêter de
boire ça c'est bien oui c'est mon
nouveau challenge c'est formidable vous
mourrez guéri je vous rabonne
alors est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
nostalgique de l'époque de femmes
libérée non non c'est déjà pas dans ma
nature disons il y a des périodes que
j'ai bien aimé mais non je suis pas du
tout c'est pas mon c'est pas mon truc là
vraiment pas du tout mais en même temps
c'est doublé du fait que je n'ai pas de
regrets non plus donc globalement ça va
quoi
c'est une vie c'est une route il y en a
des milliers comme ça des routes faut
les accepter on fait pas toujours ce
qu'on veut dit ce qu'on peut et si
c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil
je peux pas me poser cette question tu
peux pas il y a pas un moment où j'ai
pris une mauvaise décision sûrement je
veux dire je
j'ai pas envie de me poser la question
là j'aurais peut-être dû non non
demain elles sont en tout cas pour moi
demain sera plus intéressant qu'hier
et le jour vous allez mourir donc en
bonne santé qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on écrive sur votre tombe on pourrait
écrire je vous avais dit que je n'allais
pas bien ouais
l'homme enfin libéré merci cookie c'est
très heureux de rallumer la lumière sur
vous merci merci beaucoup Thierry et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu